[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
yo
what up everybody you just tapped into
the group chat live in the bleacher
report app presented by fanduel i'm greg
ivory alongside she's back yes live
moods
and we are now on every
thursday instead of tuesday so mark
those calendars but big news big news
this week for louisiana
sports betting goes live tomorrow
morning live so fanduel is offering
something very very special to those of
you in louisiana live talk to the people
and tell them what's up
yeah that's right fanduel is offering a
100 bonus to bettors in louisiana if you
register early before fanduel goes live
there tomorrow so you guys know what to
do rush over to the fanduel sportsbook
get that 100
so that we can cash out all weekend
live i gotta go i gotta know i gotta
know you talking about cashing out all
weekend long if you was go get this
honey if fanduel was gonna bless you
with a honey
what would your hundred dollar lock be
for this weekend
tomorrow i'm looking at the grizzlies at
home taking on the jazz a western
conference matchup here the grizzlies i
feel like are still trying to prove
where they stand in this western
conference because i think they're still
being underestimated john moran doing
john moran mvp type thing so i'm rocking
with the grizzlies at home
liv's rocking with the grizzlies there's
a game on saturday it's on abc
we got nets taking on the warriors you
guys already know what side i'm rocking
with there's no kd on the nets i'm
rocking with the warriors that's what i
would do with that hunted but no matter
where you live as always right here
right now we are giving away locks we're
giving away hoodies and we are giving
away jersey so get in those comments
start using your twitter fingers your
instagram fingers yo bleaching report
fingers whatever you want to call it
get in those comments give me gifts
emojis but most importantly live
i think they know the phrase by now you
know the phrase the phrases please
tell them man that's what we need we
need winners only please
in fact and not the producer just
whispered in my ear give away a jersey
so i'm about to give away a jersey right
now to somebody in the comments and i
see i see benny benny snapaholic
he says cat double double i like cat
to have a decent game to have a decent
game vegas is calling me live but i i
can't i got to tell them no but i like i
like i like my guy cat to have a decent
game so therefore therefore snappaholic
you are walking away with the jersey of
your choice
uh live
it's tnt thursday i mean fanduel is
boosting the three by two in into the
fanduel's threesome boosting the three
by two tonight in both games not just
one but both games the question is will
there be two three pointers in the first
three minutes of the game today we asked
you on twitter which three by two will
cash tonight is it the lakers taking on
the 76ers or is it the wolves the
timberwolves taking on those golden
state warriors and here are the results
there they are and uh i'm not surprised
to be honest but what i need all you
guys to do is get in the comments and
tell us which 3x2 is a lock live both
three by twos or plus money tonight
which one is your favorite
yeah i'm i'm riding with the public here
i mean this is a timberwolves team that
ranks first in three-pointers attempted
and second and three-pointers made the
warriors rank third in three-pointers
attempted and fourth in three-pointers
made not to mention in the last meeting
between these two teams there were eight
attempted three-pointers in the first
three minutes i imagine we see a game
tonight that is paced very similarly
they're gonna take a lot of shots early
from the three-point line so give me the
timberwolves versus the warriors
liv is rocking with the timberwolves
versus the warriors but i'm about to hop
into the comments because i gotta see i
gotta see what the people are rocking
with i don't have the ipad today but i
got the handy dandy phone that vegas was
calling me on had to put them on hold
because this is the group chat and i'm
we got to give these locks so we can
beat vegas today uh i see
i see
the cip99
i need to finish cooking before i can
comment i hope you finish cooking
brother and uh
we're gonna sing you a hoodie we're
gonna send you a hoodie why not because
we show love here
officially ronald though officially
ronald officially ronald's in the
comments saying easy both golden state
and the t wolves is easy lock i think
they're talking about the three by two
so shout out to you officially ronald
you're walking away woody i got one more
in me one more money merv money merv
got steph curry shooting the three gif
in the comments so shout out to you
money murph you are also walking away
with a hoodie but live
the people have spoken
imma make a decision
we are riding we are riding with the
minnesota timberwolves taking on the
golden state warriors three by two today
so let's all get rich all right liv
let's talk player points for tonight's
minnesota golden state warriors game i
need everybody to get in those comments
and tell us your best bet let's take a
look at the current odds and live talk
to me talk to the people at home
what do you like
yes i am heavy on andrew wiggins tonight
in this revenge game versus his old team
this season in the two games he's played
the timberwolves he's averaging 23.5
points per game his line is at 16 and a
half i love that he's also facing a
timberwolves team that in the last seven
has given up the seventh most points
and the second most threes to opposing
small forwards which leads me to my next
point i also like andrew wiggins over
one and a half made threes here i think
he's taken a lot of shots from the
three-point line he's hit this over the
two times that he's played the wolves
this season so i like him revenge game
in this spot to score very well
offensively for the warriors and also
shoot the three ball very well so i'm
taking over 16 and a half with a little
sprinkle on his threes as well
okay liv i i see what you're doing there
a wiggins facing his former team revenge
game let's get let's get back at them uh
you're connecting the dots i see you i
see you uh i actually want let's pull
the graphic back up because i want to
show you guys something i want to show
you guys something uh let's the top the
top you guys see that name carl anthony
towns no he doesn't play for the golden
state warriors yes he plays for the
minnesota timberwolves and i'm talking
about him his over under sitting at 22
and a half
i'm gonna go over here's why he scored
26 the last time he faced the golden
state warriors his highest point total
in his last seven games the warriors are
also they're also a small team they're
relatively small they don't have james
weisman yet
i think kat is big down low and i think
he can put up some points today uh
i'm rocking with my man cat to go over
i'm not saying
they're going to win the game but i do
think kat can get his tonight uh i'm in
the comments right now liv it's time to
go to the comments because
we got to see what the people are
talking about and we got to give away
hoodies and we also got to give away
jerseys today but right now we're giving
away hoodies and i'm in the comments and
i see matt smith 14 says
clay all day baby he's rocking with
clay's uh over i'm assuming so shout out
to you a snappaholic is back he says
clay20 no he says cat to go over 22 and
a half which is my pick and clay
to hit
to go under on threes and steph over on
points you already got a hoodie snap
hollow appreciate you and i got chris
veazey says cat double double is money
tonight
shout out to everybody that i mentioned
you all are walking away where the
hoodies live it's time for my favorite
part of the show let's talk major
markets money lines against the spreads
and point totals for tonight's game
let's take a look at the odds list
what are you seeing
and what do you like here
yeah i mean i think we've talked about
it a ton uh already in this show i like
over 228 and a half in that timberwolves
warriors game there are a lot of
three-point shooters on that team
between steph you've got pool i'm
banking on wiggins you like cat to have
a game i think russell has a big game as
well lots of three-point shooters on
these two teams
and like i said earlier the timberwolves
rank
second for three-pointers made right now
and the warriors ranked fourth for
three-pointers made i think it's a
high-scoring affair lots of
three-pointers lots of points so give me
the over
[Music]
lives rocking with the over i don't
dislike that liv i do not dislike that
at all
uh
can we pull that graphic back up because
i want to show the people something i
got to show you guys something there's
the graphic uh you guys see
the money line section i want to dibble
and dabble there but i'm not just going
to pick one game i'm going to pick two
poor ladies we're gonna go with both
favorites i'm gonna rock with the
philadelphia 76ers taking on the lakers
with no lebron we know how they've been
playing this whole year up and down up
and down i like the sixers i like how
the way my man joel embiid has been and
he's been on an absolute terror live
he's been on an absolute terror we're
going to talk about that later in the
show but uh
i like the sixers in that matchup and in
the later game in the latter game i like
the warriors in that matchup they are on
this extended home stand and um
they're looking to get on track they're
looking to get on track and they've been
doing fairly well so i i think that
they're going to keep the winning going
today against those minnesota
timberwolves but let me talk to the
people right now liv let me hop over to
my handy dandy iphone and see what they
are talking about in the comments right
now oh richie 21 says 76ers warriors
moneyline parlay is a lock shout out to
you richie you are walking away with a
hoodie hey br bedding is in the comments
said parlay g you already know they took
me back to vegas 2019 right there liv
that that's when i used to be parlaying
left and right man uh but shout out to
br betting in the comments
hey here we go wet weiner wet wayneer is
kinda he's kinda fading my first play
he's going lakers moneyline warriors
moneyline hey wet wayneer
we here on
the squad i know we here on the group
chat we are not haters so although you
like the other side i'm gonna send you a
hoodie so shout out to you brother uh
liv
let's move on to the next segment of the
show we are talking props we are talking
props props props all right we talked
major market
let's talk some props it's time for lock
or not i'm gonna put up a prop and i
need all of you in the comments
to tell me whether or not it is a lock
or not live
are you ready
i'm ready let's do it
let's get right to it let's get right to
it first up is clay thompson to make
three or more three-pointers sitting at
minus
126.
live talk to me talk to the people at
home do you like this one or do you not
i do like this one i mean it goes to my
point earlier with taking the over i
think we see a lot of three-point shots
in this game i think it's highly
offensive lots of points on the board
and as clay is figuring out his
offensive role on this warriors team and
figuring out his rhythm we're kind of
seeing a little bit of up and down from
him but when draymond green stepped away
from this warriors team we saw a lot of
figuring out what our roles are here and
i think that klay thompson is finally
getting that figured out
he's also facing a timberwolves team
that has been give as on an average has
given up 3.48
threes per game to the opposing shooting
guard position so klay thompson's in a
good spot tonight to hit some threes and
that would help my over so i'm gonna say
it's a lot
ah livs is rocking with my guy clay lip
i'm right there behind you my guy clay
hit this mark in three out of the last
four games that he have played he hit
this mark
in three out of the last four so we but
the thing is lift the point i wanted to
make today is we know clay is gonna put
up the shots like it's just a matter of
them going in but i i i feel confident
knowing that klay thompson if i put
money on him to to shoot three pointers
that he's actually gonna shoot those
three pointers
you guys are getting what i'm saying so
with that being said with all that being
said
i got a few numbers uh just in the last
four games how many uh three point
attempts my guy clay thompson and
schaden
has put up
five seven seven no five seven eight
eight so
i i i the the numbers are there clay go
make three of those
i can see him doing it he's been doing
it for majority of his career so i'm
rocking with you over here uh
i'm in the comments right now i'm in the
comments
looking for takes
looking for locks uh
here we go i see
i see sada williams say to williams say
live you are right shout out to you sada
you were walking away with a hoodie um
here we go i got d green 74 they need
draymond to score more easier that is a
great great great point because draymond
makes this offense click he makes the
offense flow he makes the offense move
so brother you are not not wrong about
that they do need draymond to make this
offense more potent than what it is but
i think my guy clay can go get three
even without drake liv
but let's move on let's move on
we got d'angelo russell
deloading to have eight or more assists
tonight liv this is plus
money
talk to us
do you like this one or do you not
i don't and it's not because i don't
think he's capable of hitting this over
the reason that i'm fading this is
because i actually like him in the spot
tonight to do more scoring so i don't
really want him to be facilitating i
want him offensively to be scoring
points and i think that's what his role
is going to be tonight now
could he be forking it over to cat
throughout the game to help you out with
your points prop absolutely so this has
the potential to hit without a doubt but
i like this position for him from a
scoring perspective more than a
facilitating perspective so that's the
only reason i worry about this assist
prop is because i think he's going to
hold on to the ball quite a bit tonight
and do a lot of the scoring so i'm going
to say it's not a lock it's definitely
possible but i like his role to be more
scoring tonight than facilitating lin
liv you like those revenge games huh you
you mentioned eight wiggins earlier
scoring tonight against his former deal
now we got d loading d loading facing
his former team the golden state
warriors and you see him scoring tonight
hey i don't dislike that i don't dislike
we see it time after time
players that play their former teams
usually like to have a knight they
usually do like to have a knight
so i don't dislike that
but liv
i'm going to rock with the over here and
here's why
d-loading had 12 assists the last time
he faced this warriors team and him and
cat i mean i've mentioned earlier in the
show i thought cat was going to be
scoring tonight and they like to play
the pick and roll game you know the
pick-and-roll game up top where cap
comes and and sets a pick for deloading
and then he rolls and then guess what d
lowly throws him the ball or he shoots
sometimes but i see him throwing him the
ball a lot cap being down low the
warriors are small
finishing and that results in deloading
getting those assists so i'm rocking
with d loading to go over eight assists
and you mentioned he's facing his former
team
maybe triple delta i don't know no i'm
not gonna say i don't think he's getting
trouble dubstep but he probably can do
he probably could go double double you
know what i mean or something you know
i'm saying but uh i'm not going with the
over but let me get into the comments
let me get into the comments
to see what they are talking oh money
merv is back in the comments says
deloading is not a lock uh
wagsworld10 says ivory is on point today
shout out to both of y'all y'all are
walking away with
hoodies um
bears for life said nah he tripping on
this one so i think he's talking about
me tripping thinking dean loden's going
over but guess what brother you are also
walking away with the hoodie so last
three people that i said you guys are
all walking with hoodies finally liv
finally
the last prop we got jared vanderbilt
to snag 12 or more rebounds
plus money plus 148
um live talk to me talk to the people
how do you feel about this
not loving it uh i mean 12 rebounds is a
is a good rebounding night and i
i don't know if he's capable of this i
also think that carl anthony towns is
going to be grabbing a lot of boards
tonight so i think that takes away from
jared getting those boards and i also
like looney i like looney to step up
tonight obviously we don't have draymond
green for this warriors team and that
has hurt them in a lot of ways but i
like looney to really step up tonight
get some of those rebounds also
like i said carl anthony towns is
probably going to be doing a little bit
of everything tonight which includes
getting rebounds which will take away
from this 12th plus so i'm gonna say not
a lock
yeah i'm right there with you liv 12's a
lot
you mentioned cat you mentioned looney
my guy averages nine and nine point two
on the regular season uh i'm i'm staying
away from this i'm not even gonna bet it
i mean i wouldn't agree i'm staying away
i'm still i'm staying away from this one
uh let me get in the comments though let
me see what they are talking about
uh all money njc says not he gonna have
eight boards shout out to you my boy
jared glow did what we did liv he said
pass
uh i don't think he's gonna touch this
one uh
snappaholics back in there there's a lot
of there's a lot of no's in the comments
uh so shout out to everybody that i
mentioned you are walking away with a
hoodie live
it's time to build the br betting custom
same game parlay which you at home yes
you that i'm talking to you you can ride
along with us
on fanduel tonight we are looking at the
lakers sixers game and i need everybody
to get in the comments and tell me
what they think
which legs are locks which legs are not
which leg they're gonna use in their
parlay which leg they're gonna take out
of this parlay just get in the comments
and use those twitter fingers whatever
you like to call them and fill those
comments up but liv are you ready are
you should we just jump right into it
let's do it let's jump right into it
all right let's get let's get right to
it like the migos said we got joel
embiid over
33 and a half points
live he's been on an absolute tear in
this in the in the month of january
talk to me do you like this one or do
you not
i mean yeah he's had 30 plus points in
the last six consecutive games this is
the type of guy that wakes up in the
morning and is good for a 30 piece with
his eyes closed i mean he's playing
basketball out of his mind he's hard to
guard right now maybe impossible to
guard
i think scoring 30 points is easy for
him this is a big game up against the
lakers no lebron james gives him a lot
more opportunities to get under that
basket and to get some shots up so
it's hard to fade him right now i mean
he's literally had 30 plus in the last
six so there's no sense in fading him
tonight especially with no lebron james
for this lakers team so yes i'm gonna
ride with this i love it i think it's
great
ah yes we are getting the good vibes
from liv on the first leg
that is a win now let's move on to the
next leg let's move on to the next leg
we're talking about russell westbrook
over 18 and a half points live
do you like this one are you iffy
are you staying away how you feeling
uh this is one that i would i would just
tread lightly with because one of two
things could happen obviously we have
anthony davis coming back um and trying
to kind of get reacclimated to this
lakers team and figure out his role uh
so that kind of takes away from
westbrook's role but in the same token
no lebron james gives westbrook a lot
more opportunities to do that
facilitating his off his offense lately
is terrifying uh it's it's terrifying to
bet on and it's terrifying to watch he
finally seems like he's getting in a
rhythm but 18 and a half
makes me nervous this is probably the
one leg i am not sure about just because
of the inconsistencies we've seen from
him in the past few weeks he does seem
like he's heating up so there is hope it
is possible no lebron james he has a lot
more opportunities to score um but this
one makes me nervous
[Music]
you said it right there no lebron james
i think russ comes out and be aggressive
if there's no lebron james
i like this one i like this one but
let's move on to the final leg of the
parlay
i mentioned it earlier
live talk to me do you like this one or
do you not we're talking about the
philadelphia 76ers money line tonight
taking on those los angeles lakers
i love it i think i've talked about this
many times with many teams in the nba i
think the most dangerous thing that any
nba team can have right now is chemistry
and the lakers don't have that and now
you're removing the glue that holds them
together in lebron james i don't feel
great about it that's not to say that i
think that they can't hang with this
76ers team but at the end of the day i
think chemistry and coaching matter a
whole lot more
than talent sometimes and i don't think
well one you took away the lakers talent
and you took away the glue that holds
their chemistry together i think that
the 76ers at home will get a win here
loving loving loving philly moneyline
liv is loving the philly money line i'm
also loving the philly money line but i
want to put this ticket up because i
want to show you guys if you guys was to
go to fanduel and place this bed in what
the odds would be and if you guys go put
a hundred dollars down you will be
walking away with 447
dollars and 18 cents there it is we did
a
leg this time we did a three leg i like
to call these three leg guarantees uh
but lift but before i get into the
comments before i get into the comments
what are you grading
the parlay
b-plus because i like it
and i think it can hit
and i'm loving philly moneyline i'm
loving embiid
i'm just gonna wish upon a star that
westbrook does what he needs to do
and hits it for us so b plus passing
grade you're still a great student but
they were your thesis statement was off
in your in your essay so yeah you know
not an a but a b plus so yeah what
westbrook just needs to show up and do
his job
b plus gets the job done i'm taking that
every single time uh hey i just want to
say last time liv gave us a b plus
we hit so
feeling the connection here i'm feeling
the connection uh it's time for me to
hop into these comments because i'm
giving away hoodies and i'm also giving
away a jersey
i'm in the comments and i got larry
segura says this will be rush show
tonight no lbj and 80 on minutes
restriction okc russ locked and loaded
hey you know what larry i love that take
so shout out to you you are walking away
with a jersey
of your choice uh i'm back into the
comments now i'm back into the comments
because it's time to give out some
hoodies
i got shane cabins zero nine fifteen
says lakers money line eighties gonna
check joelle tonight shout out to you
you're walking away with a hoodie uh i
also have one more hoodie i got
slaydig8807
greg i love it the same game parlay i'm
here for my hoodie username
slaydig8807 hook me up bro and b plus is
passing guess what slaydig8807
you got yourself your hoodie so shout
out to you brother uh
thank you for tapping in to this
to the group chat but let's move on liv
because it's time to talk futures it's
time to talk futures joel embiid is
currently on a career
best
heater right now since christmas he
leads the league in scoring
and is top 15 and rebounds and blocked
shots he is closing in on the favorite
position to win mvp today we asked you
on the app
if joelle and b
can win mvp i need you guys to get in
the comments and tell me if you think he
can overtake stefan giannis but let's
take a look at the odds and live do what
you do best talk to us
what's your take on mvp odds
yeah i mean i you know greg i hate to
break it to you and there's this is
there's no disrespect here but steph
curry to me is too high i mean i
don't agree with where he's sitting
right now i don't think that he's
playing like an mvp
mvp means most valuable player who
brings the most value to this warriors
team and we're not seeing that from
steph right now as a matter of fact i'm
starting to wonder if draymond green is
not the mvp of this warriors team
because we saw a completely different
version of them when draymond green was
out that is not to deny steph curry's
talent he is still insanely talented but
you're talking you're up against giannis
you're up against embiid you're up
against jokic that's kind of my top
three right now i think steph curry
needs to be moved down a little bit i'm
not impressed with what he's doing
lately and beat is absolutely playing
like an mvp
i do think it's a little bit of a
popularity contest that they're gonna go
with somebody that the people love i can
see that in giannis and jokic both i
love embiid i don't know if everybody
loves embiid um so for that reason it's
good value i would grab it because i
think he's absolutely playing like an
mvp but i would say giannis and jokic
right now are my top two and i've got a
plus 3200 bet on jamma rant so i'm going
to ride with him all the way through the
season
[Music]
i like that i like the john morant pick
i like the job marant pick but uh
liv
i mean
i'm behind you i i just think joelle
embiid he you could consider sprinkling
some money on him you can consider
sprinkling some money on my guy joel and
beat the way he's been playing he's been
absolutely bawling only thing you just
hope and pray and i pray that my guy
stays healthy that's it and that's all
but i want to talk about the month that
my man
joel embiid had in january i'mma just
list off some of his point totals for
the month and just just take a listen 42
38 40 50 32 32 25 31 31 31 like come on
my guy has been absolutely ballin
there's a reason there's a reason he's
next to steph curry and giannis
now live you've said you said some
interesting things about wardell you
said some really interesting things
about wardell
i i agree with you though i will agree
with you the last month my guy wardell
has not been playing like how he was
earlier in the season but let's not
forget how he was playing earlier in
this season he was on a tear just like i
know he was on his absolutely i need
consistency that's all we have there is
time there is so much time left he
absolutely i i am not worried about
steph curry it's just you know right now
not really feeling his vibe at the
moment but he's that time
lately lately he hasn't been doing what
he's been doing majority of the year and
i i totally understand that i understand
your point but i just want you and the
people at home to remember please
remember what this man was doing earlier
in the season but i also want to say i
just think my guy steph got heavy legs
live i'm gonna be honest i think he got
stepped heavy legs he's been battling
he's been carrying the wares team
especially before clay uh and i think he
has heavy legs but guess what liv guess
what's right around the corner
the all-star break
and there's a lot of basketball left
after the all-star break
my guy's gonna rest up those legs and go
on this playoff push and you guys are
gonna see so uh i'm still rocking with
the home team i'm still rocking with my
boy steph
but i but joe ellen beat he's uh
he's catching my eye and i'm willing to
sprinkle some money on it i'm willing to
sprinkle some money on it but live i
mean we we reached the end it's it's
thank you to everybody thank you to
everybody for tapping into the group
chat presented by fanduel please
remember what you learned today
the warriors
timberwolves 3x2 that is what we are
riding with we are calling it a lock but
i need you guys to get on fanduel and
tell our br betting same game parlay
if you live in louisiana get on fanduel
and take advantage of the
early 100 that they are giving you guys
for signing up we'll be back next week
giving out more hoodies giving out more
jerseys and more locks if you want a
hoodie
we will dm you
alongside live moods i'm greg ivory me
and live we're leaving the group chat
peace
[Music]
so
you